but leave it to a favorite outlet of the
left to expose those assertions as
utterly false a new report by The
Huffington Post proclaims everyone got
the pulse master story completely wrong
details have the trialed matine's wife
nor salman revealed his assault at the
nightclub was a crime of random
opportunity and driven by an allegiance
to isis joining us now with reaction
counterterrorism analyst elisa deft re
lisa thanks so much for being here good
pleasure so my first question is why is
it that whenever we have some sort of
terrorist attack like this god forbid on
american soil or overseas quite frankly
does the left and the media
automatically go to finding a motive
that has nothing to do with the actual
situation yeah that's that's the
question here right now is to say we had
plenty of evidence to know that this man
pledged allegiance to isis he said on
facebook and at other times that his
actions were in retaliation for the
bombings in syria yet because this was
at a gay nightclub it became a hate
crime question becoming why is the media
so quick to mute or to erase the jihadi
narrative is it because we want to be so
politically correct and not marginalized
you know the the LGBT community here or
is it because they truly don't want to
or want to ignore the real threat here
which is that there are Americans who
are being recruited who are pledging
allegiance who live right here in the
United States and the answer to that is
that if you are fearful of perhaps being
insensitive to a small minority group
you're being more insensitive to
American the American people and really
belittling them when you are not
thinking of of the larger security issue
here well you bring up that narrative I
want to put up on the screen a couple of
quotes from mainstream media members in
the aftermath of the Poulos nightclub
shooting Daily Beast Tim teaming said at
the time let's say it plainly this was a
mass slang aimed at LGBT people this was
a homophobic act New Republic's jeet
here also arguing the same thing the
orlando massacre was undeniably a
homophobic hate crime and then here US
News James Robbins says numerous
subsequent reports that Omar had strong
homosexual urges paints a picture of a
young man trying to reconcile
in her feelings with his strongly
homophobic Muslim culture but now that
we've been through the trial of the wife
we're seeing that this had nothing to do
with his actual motive explain that when
you this this attack first time and you
had some in-depth reporting exclusive
reporting on the motive in this attack
yeah absolutely and why the myopic view
why does this need to check just one box
why do we have to say workplace violence
or the person was mentally unstable or
whatever it may be and the answer here
is that the person who does pledged
allegiance to Isis who does have this
just jihadi point of view does beat his
wife which we came to now find out he
does probably hate gays which he
randomly came upon this nightclub so why
this narrow view to shut out or to
discredit or preclude any kind of
narrative and now that we have almost
like extracted the narrative that this
was a hate crime why was this why was
there such a push to get the rid of the
real narrative which is with jihadism
the one thing that I did report on right
after this was a in al-qaeda media
basically on on their online news outlet
they put out this kind of alert to want
to be jihadis telling them if you are
going to launch an attack make sure that
you don't do it on a minority group
because piggybacking off of this attack
they thought Americans will only take
the blame themselves if it's a hate
crime so make sure if you are to launch
an attack that it's in the name of jihad
and it's only against white Americans so
that they know that this was purely
jihad they want the credit they wanted
to be branded and we allowed them in
this situation for two years to get away
with a false narrative well we're
running out of time out of time but just
going over this case it seems like
looking at all the facts when the
warning signs were ignored about
jihadism by a number of law enforcement
agencies and here we are now as you
mentioned with the narrative for years
on end being about a hate crime rather
than addressing the real issue and
trying to prevent it in the future
final word
absolutely and I think there the this
the false you you know kind of thing
that's coming out about this now even in
The Huffington Post piece is that this
is stuff that came to light after the
trial and that's absolutely not true we
knew all of these pieces of evidence
when the crime happened that he pledged
allegiance to Isis that he was doing
this to retaliate for the crimes that
so-called crimes that America is
committing in Syria and this was all
really to just take away from the real
narrative that this was jihad and this
was Islamic terrorism well these are
deft re one of the best thank you for
coming on